Hi.
You’re beautiful.
Can I scratch your ears?
Nice, sweet girl.
You're making a mess.
Those uh, some of
the little girls from the extras department and stuff
were out there feeding them or uh apples all morning.
Oh really?
So yeah they’re probably
pretty full.
Are you all tired of apples?
- Should I have brought
you some cheese?
- I don’t think they can ever get completely tired of them but...
I should have brought you something else sweetheart.
You just take a little bite.
You’re such a lady.
Here, wipe your hands
on my chaps.
- There you go.
- Thank you.
Ok sweet girl.
Can I say bye to you?
Okay, so let's let's go through this
a couple of times if
you don't mind.
Mollie why don’t you just take a step back.
Take a step back.
Let George have the horse. Go down and turn horse.
Guys, give us a little room.
Back off.